bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de municipales 2014 l'essentiel
de la campagne électorale à saint
quentin en yvelines et dans les
principales villes du département pour
débuter ce piratage du site internet du
candidat divers-droite etienne erasmus à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la tête de liste
réussir à une désagréable surprise en se
rendant sur son site de campagne
entre photos le caricaturant et d
attaque personnelle également sur ses
choix et sur ses relations avec d'autres
responsables politiques dans la commune
à toutes les informations officielles le
concernant ont tout simplement disparu
selon lui les responsables tons sont à
chercher parmi des anciens membres de sa
propre équipe
j'ai découvert lundi matin effectivement
un piratage puisque seul mot de mon site
informatique qui était en fait réalisé
par deux de mes anciens colistiers
je déplore ce genre de comportement
surtout quand ils sont dus à des
considérations d'intérêt personnel
puisqu'il s'agissait uniquement
d'obtenir des places alors qu'eux mêmes
ils avaient été je dirais correctement
positionné sur ma liste
ils ont cru intelligent de diffuser
parallèlement au piratage du site
internet un mail aux sympathisants de
réussir annonçant je cite la mort de
réussir donc ce que j'ai évidemment
démenti immédiatement en maintenant et
en confirmant que réussir était toujours
vivant et toujours en course pour les
élections municipales et pour la ville
de saintes par rapport à cette
utilisation frauduleuse
il faut bien le dire du site de réussir
puisque
il ya d'une part de la diffamation il ya
d'autre part de l'utilisation de marque
alors que le nom et la marque réussir
sont déposés donc cette utilisation
frauduleuse donnera lieu à des
poursuites et un dépôt de plainte c'est
bien mon attention car encore une fois
il n'ya pas question de céder au
chantage et de tolérer ou de cautionner
des pratiques illégales
ils ont moins de trente ans au coeur de
la génération y est ils font mentir
leurs aînés qui les juge peu intéressés
par ce scrutin le reportage de la
rédaction à présent sur ces jeunes
candidat tête de liste dans les yvelines
ils ont moins de trente ans au coeur de
la génération y et son tête de liste
dans les yvelines pour ses prochaines
municipales c'est principalement l'ump
qui a décidé de miser sur le renouveau
de ses candidats pour tenter de
l'emporter dans des bastions de la
gauche
attrape magny les hameaux lui en cours
ou encore comme ici à la veille
c'est ma première expérience en
politique de la première élection je
travaille pour la mairie d'elancourt
pour le maire d'elancourt donc je
connais bien la gestion d'une ville
je suis sans étiquette j'ai jamais fait
partie d'aucun mouvement politique après
j'ai des valeurs très fort des
convictions personnelles très présente
être jeune pour un candidat aux
municipales atout ou handicap leurs
aînés leur reproche un manque
d'expérience il mise sur le dynamisme
rappelons tout de même qu'un certain
nicolas sarkozy l'emportait à neuilly
sur seine
à 28 ans et à l'ump justement hors
berger depuis magny les hameaux se
verrait bien renouveler cet exploit
même si elle reconnaît la difficulté des
classe politique à se renouveler c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal aujourd'hui à
renouveler nos élus on a du mal à
renouveler en termes de génération on a
du mal à renouveler faire appel à la
diversité est aussi à faire appel à la
parité et je crois que pour ma
génération sera quelque chose de naturel
parce qu'on a toujours vécu avec des
gens issus la diversité avec des gens
plus jeunes avec des gens 20 des femmes
des hommes
je pense que c'est plus encore une fois
une question de génération et de
renouvellement engagé en politique
depuis 2001 tous n'ont en revanche pas
le même rapport avec la politique
s'il a dit cela secouera a pris sa carte
à l'ump à 16 ans d'autres comme othman
massereau gardent leurs distances pas
encore encartés il préfère se revendique
gaulliste tout en se disant non
partisans ump mais aussi fn mise sur les
moins de 30 ans à plaisir
notamment ou aleksandar nikolic se
défend les couleurs du rassemblement
bleu marine
lui qui à 27 ans a débuté son engagement
politique avec l'extrême gauche en
dehors de l'échiquier politique sans
étiquette on notera aussi l encours la
présence d'une liste menée par un
collectif génération solidaire
ce manque d'expérience je pense que ça
ne veut pas dire un manque de
compétences et bien au contraire
on est en train de rassembler une équipe
très compétente donc que ce soit dans le
domaine budgétaire comme vous ai dit
c'est un domaine auquel je me connais
vraiment beaucoup et le développement
économiques dans le dos dans le domaine
social dans le domaine de la solidarité
domaine aussi des travaux publics on
essaie de développer les choses au
niveau de l'éducation
donc je pense qu'au niveau de la
compétence que les compétences que les
projets que les idées et aussi que la
motivation est vraiment la moyenne d'âge
en france des nerfs 57 ans selon l'étude
menée par un sociologue en 2012 est
reprise dans le quotidien les échos
reste à voir si le scrutin permettra
cette année de faire baisser cette
moyenne dont le reste des yvelines on
notera que les listes menées par des
jeunes trentenaires sont aussi
nombreuses et du divers droite grégoire
leclercq à rambouillet 31 ans à vivien
gasc socialiste de 33 ans à montigny le
bretonneux et à propos de vivien gasc
dont il est question à la fin de ce
sujet sachez qu'il s'étonne vient a
communiqué aujourd'hui de l'attitude du
modem départemental à son égard le
candidat socialiste a en effet été
rejoint par un membre de la formation
centriste jean marc oursin mais
récemment sur notre antenne sur
l'antenne de tv fils le vice-président
départemental expliquez lui apporter son
soutien à michel laugier le maire
sortant candidat de l'ump de lui dit
vivien gasc qu'ils parlent maintenant de
non respect de la démocratie alors que
les militants du modem de sa commune ont
choisi de partir en campagne à ses côtés
et puis la campagne toujours qui prend
une toute autre tournure à rambouillet
le divers-droite grégoire leclercq que
l'on a aperçu tout à leur porte plainte
contre le front national
en cause un tract distribué par les
équipes de l'un de ses opposants le
candidat philippe chevrier et grégoire
leclercq qui parle d' attaques gratuites
et diffamatoires qu'il s'agisse de
collusion avec la presse de détournement
de biens sociaux ou encore de conflit
d'intérêts avec la paroisse jusqu'au 23
mars vous le savez sur cette antenne
nous vous proposons de découvrir lé
candidat qui s'engage sur votre commune
ce soir nous partons pour plaisir dans
cette ville de 31 mille habitants quatre
listes pour la maire sortant en poste
depuis seulement deux ans après le
départ de son prédécesseur en cours
mandat joël regnault cette campagne est
une première en tant que tête de liste
ump
pendant qu'à gauche deux listes l'une du
ps l'autre du front de gauche se
disputent les faveurs des électeurs etc
en embuscade le front national entend
lui créer la surprise
présentation donc avec clark envier à
plaisir l'actuel maire josefina coleman
ce berger brigue un nouveau mandat
l'occasion pour elle de se soumettre
pour la première fois au scrutin
populaire car l'ancien maire joël
regnault lui a confié les rênes de la
ville en 2012 après 12 ans à la tête de
plaisir depuis 2001 elle était adjointe
au maire en charge de la culture et de
la communication ça vaut la peine peut
être de continuer avec une équipe qui a
fait preuve d'une responsabilité ça qui
compte en premier la responsabilité
puisque haut niveau ne serait ce que de
la gestion de la ville je pense que les
plaisirs aujourd'hui sont en confiance
totale par rapport à ce qu'ils ont pu
connaître dans d'autres temps parmi ses
arguments la gestion de la ville la
réhabilitation du centre historique et
la modernisation de la commune
on a beaucoup amélioré déjà les voiries
sec sur plaisir on a plus de 100 km de
voirie dante c'est lourd c'est important
on vient de commencer la plus longue
route de plaisir qui la rue des sablons
qui doit être mise en état et on
réfléchit bien sûr à tous les pistes
cyclables et circulations douces ou la
mer compte également moderniser le
quartier du vélib ou encore porter le
projet d'un cinéma pour 2015 ce qui
plaît aux habitants selon elle sa
proximité avec eux c'est ce que j'ai
envie de donner d'être à l'écouté puis
et puis de dire non quand je ne peux pas
dire oui
et dans ce cas-là promettre fr c'est ça
qui m'importe
on compte sur vous
face à elles trois candidats bernard
ansart déjà candidat pour les
municipales de 2008 se présente sous une
liste d'union
bernard ansart via plaisir depuis 40 ans
avec sa femme et ses deux enfants
c'est dans cette région qu'il a fait sa
carrière de simple ouvrier chez renault
à ses débuts il est devenu directeur de
gamme marketing il s'est engagé en
politique il ya maintenant douze ans
après l'échec de la gauche aux élections
présidentielles 2002 mais c'est d'abord
pour son investissement dans le monde
associatif qui s'est fait connaître dans
la ville comme avec plaisir vestiaire du
monde associatif au monde politique
il n'y avait qu'un pas c'est une suite
logique parce que pour moi la politique
je la vois dans le bourg serbe dans le
bon sens du terme
c'est pas de la politique politicienne
c'est de la politique pour servir et
c'est tout l'objet de mon programme
accompagner les habitants dans leur
quotidien et leur amener le meilleur
dans ce qui est possible aujourd'hui il
est dans l'opposition au conseil
municipal dans son programme il annonce
plus de démocratie locale avec
l'instauration des conseils de quartier
le but être à l'écouté des habitants
mais aussi développer une vie de
quartier avec l'aménagement du centre
ville
la mise en place d'animations et de
voies de circulation douce mais
également je voudrais met en très très
rapidement au début du mandat des
navettes un dock qui fasse que durant la
journée les gens puissent se rendre de
leur quartier vers le centre-ville
ouvert des points administratifs ou les
points commerciaux de façon plus facile
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça manque
énormément
autre élément avancé la création d'une
pépinière d'entreprises pour favoriser
les emplois locaux
quant aux finances de la ville il
conteste la bonne santé affichée par le
maire la dette
à l'époque était de 65 millions
aujourd'hui cette bête a effectivement
été réduite mais en face de cette
réduction nous avons maintenant devant
nous des emprunts toxiques
le candidat du front de gauche rejoint
en partie bernard ansart sur ce point
la vraie différence par prononcer les
investissements qui qui auraient été
portées
je pense qu'il faut quand même accès
plus sur la jeunesse il fera que c'est
un peuple est sûre
la culture axée plus quand j ai culture
et culture contenu le sport notamment
les sports pour tous est vraiment pour
les plus grands noms de plaisir je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le souci c'est ça c'est
un petit peu trop
saupoudrez élu en 2008 conseiller
municipal avec la gauche rassemblée
djamen ya qui a quitté le groupe de
bernard ansart opposé à la politique
nationale le front de gauche ne
souhaitait pas s'allier avec le ps
diamal niati et plaisir bois depuis 2002
après douze ans comme cadre chez un
opérateur de télécommunications il
travaille aujourd'hui à son compte
marié et père de deux enfants il s'est
d'abord investi dans la ville au sein de
la fcpe
je sais un militant parce qu'on peut
résumer à cela et en tant qu'habitant
effectivement quand on est mis quand on
fait de la politique
donc je fais de la politique depuis très
longtemps mais au sens noble du terme
voilà donc la politique c'est
véritablement accès pour le plus grand
nombre et ne pas parler pour les autres
mais parler avec les autres
il souhaite d'ailleurs instaurer plus de
concertation avec les habitants pour
prendre des décisions sur la commune
derniers candidats en lice
aleksandar nikolic à 27 ans cet ancien
membre du parti communiste porte les
couleurs du front national il a intégré
le parti frontiste via le programme à
l'intérieur et la présentation devant
hausse est un très bon week-end en tout
cas merci merci beaucoup monsieur je me
suis dit qu'un moment juste gagner de
l'argent et ça m'intéressait pas donc je
me suis engagé j'ai postulé pour les
pompiers j'avais envie d'aider est
également je pensais que je pouvais
apporter en politique et m'engager aussi
l'année en politique alexander nikolic
et vit à plaisir depuis un an après
avoir passé son enfance à montain ville
dans le nord du département
après un passage par l'armée il est
aujourd'hui démonstrateur vendeur fier
d'être le premier candidat frontiste sur
plaisir
il souhaite appliquer le programme du
parti simple exemple ce fils d'immigré
serbe et portugais refuse tout
communautarisme on est un petit peu
différent des autres parce qu'un
consensus sur beaucoup de sujets et j'ai
pu le remarquer au conseil municipal
or nous c'est évidemment la lutte contre
le communautarisme du même titre qu'on
va toujours se poser à des associations
qui prônent une unité d'aidé français de
souche et on va s'opposer également à
des associations que la actuellement la
mairie subventionne je pense à des
associations comme je lé évoque dans mon
tract fraternité africaine
l'amérique c'est l'ancien une
association qui prône l'unité entre les
africains et personnes d'origine
africaine nous on ne supporte pas de 10
la division est le cas la
communautarisation de
cités françaises et notamment à plaisir
une ville quatre candidats les plaisirs
voir jusqu'au 23 mars pour faire leur
choix et les têtes de liste de ces
quatre donc candidats qui sont engagés
sont venus débattre sur tv fil 78
si vous n'étiez pas avec nous voici
quelques extraits de leurs échanges
le contact il est sur une mandature et
pas uniquement sur les trois mois qui
précèdent chose que vous faites ici bien
de façon et c'est normal vous êtes les
challengers donc c'est normal de se
fasse il porte à porte ou fassiez
connaître l'image rien à vous en dieu
que ce côté là mais je t'apporte n'ont
même pas ce qu'ont les gens me
connaissent les sciences à quand
j'entends les gens dire aujourd'hui on
voir mes lames le maire arrivé
soudainement alors qu'on l'a pas vu six
ans mais bien sûr je suis pas espérer le
23 mars
si vous le permettez je suis à finir
quelque chose par rapport à l'image
politique parce que vous parlez de
l'image politique image politique ça
suit tout au long d'une mandature
ça se fait par le respect que l'on a vis
à vis des gens ça se fait aussi sur ce
qu'on promet pendant les périodes
préélectorales et ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui sur les promesses que vous
faites les uns et des autres à la
population c'est dramatique fort étonné
vous êtes en train de me donner des
leçons de politique et autres je trouve
ça relativement conique étant donné que
vous parlez de démocratie je pense que
nous pouvons vous rappeler le manque de
démocratie nous ont fait part à l'égard
des élus d'opposition dont je fais
partie quant à ce qui concerne la pwa le
pouvoir de communication qui nous est
offert concernant les avait des nerfs
vous avez justement la question mais
c'est impossible à brest après si je me
permets je ne pourrais pas laisser seul
mais oui et donc sur le principe je suis
fort étonné vous avez eu un référé du
tribunal de verser à ce sujet jusqu'à
preuve du contraire on n'avait pas fait
montre d'une grande démocratie à notre
encontre à notre égard ce que je
reproche aujourd'hui à la mairie en
place 106 kg a pas de vision depuis 13
ans qu'ils sont en place au-delà des
aspects dont on parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure des aspects financiers
on n'a pas de vision les habitants ne
savent pas vers où on les mène on leur
avait dit il y aura plus d'urbanisme
aujourd'hui il faut y voi du bétonnage
qui fleurit à droite à gauche sans
savoir sans avoir été prévenu et sans
savoir ce que ça va devenir
on voit également les jardins familiaux
là qui sont en centre ville qui vont
disparaître au courant monsieur ça voyez
comme quoi vous avez des informations et
je ne sais pas ce que je suis à jour
quand il n'y a rien de prévu un jardin
écoutez vous nous le prouvent récit vous
êtes encore en place et il nous ferons
en sorte que ça soit fait autrement si
nous sommes même si nous sommes élus et
donc de fait il ya qu'il ya tout un
ensemble à gérer également par les voies
de circulation des voies de déplacement
les voies de stationnement
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce que les gens se
plaignent notamment les petits commerces
comme à la gare ckpa de il n'y a pas de
stationnement
on peut pas stationner et donc de fait
il ya toute une réflexion à avoir sur
des sujets qui sont croisés et qui
permettront effectivement de retrouver
une dynamique dans cette ville il ya
aussi sur peut-être des questions d'ego
je sais que comme un hamac allmendinger
a été élue elle a mis sa photo un peu
partout dans la municipalité
on nous considère que c'est des coups
des coûts inutiles et au détriment des
impôts des plaisirs war et et oui oui je
veux tout au moins un peu partout dans
la ville quand vous allez remplacer
monsieur monsieur rémy oui voilà donc il
ya énormément de deux sur des petits
points comme ça à gagner a dit
énormément d'économies à faire
un autre débat que vous avez eu
l'occasion de suivre sur téléphiles
celui consacré à la ville de la verrière
cette commune de moins de 10000
habitants qui voit s'affronter deux
listes l'une menée par alain ajaj
lui aussi d'ailleurs arrivé à la tête de
la commune à la faveur du départ de
pierre c'est lincou réélu en 2008
et puis l'autre liste menée par le sans
étiquette nicolas dainville et nicollin
dainville soutenu néanmoins par l'ump et
par l'udps et y extrait des échanges
entre les deux hommes autour notamment
des nouvelles réalisations immobilières
à venir dans le quartier des bécanes
mais aussi autour de l'attractivité
économique de la ville les bécanes c'est
très simple aujourd'hui sont des
terrains inaccessible inutilisé par les
verriers roi et donc nous allons
effectivement les redonner aux verriers
roi à travers un projet très simple
finalement dû de l'habitat diversifié
vous savez que la verrière ses 75 % de
logements sociaux
notre objectif c'est de revenir aux
alentours 50%
avec ce nouveau quartier donc de
l'habitat diversifiée pour les habitants
des commerces des services évidemment et
des espaces naturels qui sont
aujourd'hui inaccessibles qui vont être
rendus aux habitants à travers notamment
un projet assez original d'agriculture
urbaine crée simple finalement il ya une
crainte
une crainte qui est sincère qui légitime
de beaucoup de verts et roy sur le
chiffre le nombre de logement d'abord ce
chiffre a longtemps été caché on nous
annonce enfin que ces mille 800 nouveaux
logements 1800 nouveaux logements ça
veut dire doubler la population doubler
la population sur un périmètre 6 et 3
c'est pas dans l'intérêt des verriers
roanne et du village le village ils
veulent un esprit village renforcée ils
ont peur de l'arrivée massive de 6000
nouveaux habitants orly par qu'ils ont
peur au niveau de la circulation et du
stationnement
on a huit mille véhicules aujourd'hui
pour 6000 habitants combien en plus de
l'ain selon nos estimations ces 2500 à
3000 véhicules en plus même si on
développe les transports
il y aura un impact sur la circulation
et stationnement c'est déjà un
une vraie problématique pour les
habitants d'orly parc sans parler des
travaux qui devraient causer de
nombreuses nuisances et puis au bois de
l'étang
beaucoup de gens du bois de l'étang nous
disent mais on risque d'être encore plus
isolé d'abord c'est pas 6000 nouveaux
habitants évidemment ces 4000 on a déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises monsieur nabil
a du mal à entendre mais c'est pas grave
ici frôle ici fera le doublement de la
population s'était lancé dans des
documents sur la vie de la mairie
monsieur d'inviter la danse et la presse
les jours de parole est à moi s'il vous
plaît je vais donc continuer donc ses
4000 habitants en plus et pas si me
laisser sur 20 ans oui a largement le
temps que la ville se construisent
deuxièmement il ya 450 demandeurs de
logement la verrière à la verrière 450
demandeurs de logement comment expliquer
aux verriers roi qu'on a le droit de
construire à maurepas qu'on a le droit
de faire les réseaux nouveau quartier
plusieurs centaines de logements est en
cours et qu'à la verrière nous n'aurions
pas le droit de construire quand un
entrepreneur à une ville à choisir il
regarde effectivement l'accessibilité ce
n'était pas le cas avec la gare qu'est
trouvée tus il regarde la propreté
l'entretien de la ville parce que quand
on reçoit des clients c'est important
que la ville soit bien entretenu ce
n'est pas le cas et surtout il va dans
une ville où le maire dépit le tapis
rouge aux entreprises aujourd'hui je
suis désolé de le dire quand on entend
un discours de défiance vis-à-vis des
investisseurs vis-à-vis des entreprises
vis-à-vis des actionnaires
l'entrepreneur il va pas aller à la
verrière s'il ya un maire qui ne
comprend pas l'entreprise qui ne qui
n'accueille pas à bras ouverts
l'entreprise aujourd'hui que ça il ya
une désaffection vis-à-vis de la
politique sauf en vis-à-vis des mers 57%
des français reconnaissent leur mère
pourquoi ils le reconnaissent
et quand est-ce qu'ils reconnaissent
quand il est proche quand il est
respectueux quand il les regarde et qui
travaille quand il tient ses promesses
et ses engagements je ne fais pas de
promesses je prend des engagements
municipales 2014 les débats entre
candidats à chaque mardi et chaque jeudi
à 20 heures sûreté les filets rendez
vous notamment ceux ci mars avec les
têtes de listes qui se présentent à
maurepas elles sont sept 7 candidats du
centre de la gauche de la droite la
division qui règne dans cette commune
après l annonce du retrait de la vie
politique locale de georges mougeot élu
sans interruption depuis 1989 vous
entendrez également cette semaine les
candidats à elancourt une autre commune
que nous suivons vous le savez où se
présente quatre listes parmi ses
différentes listes à elancourt celle de
michel beso le socialiste qui siège dans
l'opposition depuis 2008 a réuni autour
de lui l'ensemble
à gauche reste à savoir si cela suffira
pour forcer un second tour dans une
ville où l'ancien député ump jean-michel
fourgous a réuni la dernière fois plus
de 50% des suffrages et ce dès le
premier tour du scrutin nous avons
demandé à michel beso ce qui avait
changé depuis six ans il y a 6 ans
j'étais tête de liste mais enfin de ça a
été un peu précipitée
ce qui change c'est que la majorité
sortante est profondément divisée très
profondément divisé on se retrouve avec
trois listes de droite puisque
celle qui ne s'affiche pas à gauche pour
moi elles sont à droite et ce clivage
est un bien pour la démocratie
certains me disent oui mais si tout le
monde pouvait contribuer ensemble
non il ya des choix politiques et les
changes et le c'est nécessaire pour la
démocratie qui est extraordinaire et
d'avoir pu bâtir une liste qui puisse
allier des employés des ouvriers des
chefs d'entreprise des retraités des
jeunes
vraiment tous les tous les horizons
possibles et la diversité
concernant maurepas à présent dans le
débat entre candidats sera à suivre le 6
mars sur cette antenne sachez que le
colistier du divers droite grégory gars
restiez erwan le gall vient d'être
suspendu de l'udi et du parti radical et
les instances nationales n'ont en effet
pas vraiment apprécié le ralliement de
ce dernier avec le responsable local de
l'ump élu dé qui précise que
l'investiture a bien été donné
officiellement à pire le guérinel est
tandis qu'à l'ump il n'y aura finalement
aucun candidat a soutenu on change de
commune à présent pour ce magazine des
municipales à guyancourt de listes
seulement modem et ump ayant fait
alliance dès le premier tour
la suprématie de la gauche élu
régulièrement avec des scores avoisinant
les 70% et mener cette année encore par
françois de ligne et ne sera contesté
que par un seul candidat ladislas
secouera le portrait des deux hommes
avec anthony rech
il veut proposer un nouveau modèle de
ville au guyancourt toi investi par
l'ump lui d ea l'a dit cela secouera
s'est engagé en politique à l'âge de 16
ans il a activement participé à la
campagne présidentielle de nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 et cette élève avocat de
26 ans s'est ensuite focalisé sur ses
études avant de revenir sur le terrain
politique pour les législatives et
maintenant pour les municipales à la
tête d'une liste fusionnée avec le modem
de jean loup carrière
c'est par un choix c'est quelque chose
qui s'est imposée à moi puisque j'ai 26
ans et ça fait 26 ans que j'habite à
guyancourt
j'ai habité au sol j'ai habité au bois
de la grille j'habite actuellement à la
minière donc je suis un enfant ici de
guyancourt je suis un enfant du
territoire c'est une ville qui m'a vu
grandir j'ai été à l'école ici est donc
mon engagement politique ne pouvait que
se dérouler ici dans cette ville ce fils
dit
gray polonais a fait ses premiers pas
dans le quartier des saules il souhaite
axé son programme sur trois points
l'économie locale dont les commerces de
proximité la fiscalité la sécurité la
démocratie locale
je veux instaurer beaucoup plus de
proximité avec les clients courtois est
sur le terrain être à l'écouté des gens
moi je sais que la première proposition
que je ferai si je suis élu maire en
mars 2014
et bien la mairie sera ouverte tous les
samedis au client courtois aux
associations et moi je les écouterai ça
sera pas des maires adjoints ça sera moi
mais là dit cela secouera s'attaque à un
bastion socialiste guyancourt est à
gauche depuis 1936 face à lui le maire
socialiste sortant françois de ligne et
après avoir été élu avec 73% des
suffrages dès le premier tour en 2008
françois de ligne et se présente à sa
propre succession est plutôt sereinement
une élection n'est jamais gagnée
d'avancé ça c'est le premier principe en
plus rappelons nous que s'il n'y a que
deux listes ce qui semble être le cas à
guyancourt
à ce moment là il n'y aura qu'un tour
donc c'est le 23 mars
et c'est le geste de chacun des 23 mars
qui compte et c'est seulement après
qu'on peut dire si une élection gagnée
arrivé sur la commune au quartier des
garennes
ce professeur de métier a rajeuni son
équipe en âge et en expérience avec plus
de la moitié de nouveaux colistiers
si son premier mandat avait été celui du
développement durable il mettra au coeur
de cette campagne les thèmes comme
l'éducation la solidarité et le cadre de
vie les engagements ont été tenus et
dans bien des domaines nous sommes aussi
allés au delà pour répondre aux besoins
nouveaux
pour s'adapter aux besoins nouveaux par
exemple avec la crise économique nous
avons dû renforcer les aides sociales
et puis une ville où savez c'est comme
un organisme vivant il faut savoir
s'adapter et nous l'avons fait par
exemple dans l'entretien notre cadre de
vie sur la commune il n'y aura donc que
deux listes
contrairement à 2008 où trois candidats
avaient brigué la mairie
et pour terminer cette émission des
municipales quelques dernières
informations chantal jouanno qui était à
maurepas samedi matin la sénatrice udi
de paris ancien ministre est venu
soutenir pierre leguérinel on
notera aussi lors de ce rendez vous la
présence d'hervé miclo l ancien candidat
à la candidature pour le ps sur la
commune a choisi de quitter l la
formation de gauche pour apparaître sur
la liste du représentant centriste
autres députés actuellement ministre à
s'impliquer dans cette campagne dans le
département c'est benoît hamon le
socialiste était du côté de bernard en
sarah plaisir samedi soir dans le
quartier du val hibou un quartier qui
doit actuellement faire face à de
nombreux retards dans la rénovation de
logements pour bernard ansart que vous
voyez sur ces images d'archivés s'ils
attrapent communes voisines la
rénovation urbaine a été réussi c'est le
résultat de la politique municipale une
volonté politique absente à plaisir
poursuit-il et puis un autre déplacement
mais à venir celui ci c'est bruno le
maire qui se rendra à magny les hameaux
ce mardi 4 mars pour la dernière réunion
publique de campagne d'aurore berger à
l'école saint-exupéry est la candidate
de la droite a reçu depuis l'an dernier
de nombreux soutiens nationaux
david douillet valérie pécresse gérard
larcher ont déjà fait le déplacement
bruno le maire lui a été ministre de
l'agriculture il est actuellement député
de l'eure municipales 2014 le magazine
revient mardi prochain à 18h30 le tour
de la campagne dans le département
excellente soirée